j'aimerais vraiment craquelle répondre à
cette question que j'ai posée tout à
l'heure il vous dit il a été retenu à
l'encontre d'aps à la fois fou et
antisémites exactement ça d'après ce
qu'on peut avoir une absence de
discernement et commettre un meurtre
antisémite bien pour moi et en fait non
c'est pas contradictoire ah oui parce
que parce que la folie attrape la folie
de la société dans laquelle ils se
trouvent nous sommes dans une société où
il y à de l'antisémitisme où il ya du
jihadisme où il y a voilà une guerre
terroriste qui a lieu et vous savez
historiquement en dépeignaient les fous
avec la main ex prenait pour napoléon
vous savez c'est dur de l'entonnoir
aujourd'hui c'est possible et c'est
apparemment le cas que ce fou à trappes
cette folie là et qui excusez moi mais
pourquoi je veux pas sur quoi ce serait
exclusif
moi j'étais moi je suis plutôt
satisfaite que le raccord antisémite
mais dans l'accord il est revenu quand
vous avez discernement pour savoir que
vous êtes antisémites c'est que vous
n'avez pas d' absence de discernement
désolé meilleur ami si je peux dire un
mot ce qu'on nous reproche c'est
l'absence de discernement l'abolition
l'iran parce qu'il a pu fumer du
cannabis
ça voudrait dire examine n'a jamais pris
le moindre traitement psychiatrique de
sa vie ni avant ni après il n'a jamais
été interné une minute il a pris 40 juin
et une jurisprudence qui est terrible
droite où on va dire à tous les
assassins en herbe cas de le dire aller
fut avant d'aller tuer quelqu'un ces
fumées et vous serez c'est en espagne il
a raison ça j'aurais à prononcer en fin
de matinée sur va dans ce sens la
réalité aujourd'hui la réalité raquel
garrido la justice évidemment est
indépendante elle a tranché et le
jugement est en plus irrévocable mais
l'agent 6 est faillible et là elle s'est
trompée
c'est devant une cour d'assises de la
république au nom du peuple français qui
auraient dû avoir un jugement et c'est
là où tout aurait été sur la table
il aurait pu être innocenté c'est ça la
justice mais il n'y a pas eu de justice
il a fumé des joints il a massacré
pendant 30 minutes à poings nus une
femme qu'à hurler au nom de al hadba
quand tous ces attentats islamistes qui
ont tué mes 300 français en france et y
aura pas de procès j'ai honte j'ai mal à
la france
j'ai honte de nous parce que moi je suis
législateur si ça c'est la loi la loi
est pas bonne la loi il faut la changer
quelqu'un qui a massacré une femme parce
qu'elle était juive
il doit être jugé et apple jugement s'il
jugement pour l'attentât de la rue
copernic où à l'époque raymond barre
avait dit ils voulaient tuer des
israélites il a tué des français
innocents
il n'y a pas eu à cela a pris 40 à la
tente encore un procès sur l'attentât de
la rue des rosiers qui va démarrer dans
quelques semaines y a pas eu d'attentât
il a pas eu de procès après la mort du
dj c'est l'âme
je ne sais pas si vous avez entendu
parler de ce garçon qui était plein de
talent qui est en train d'exploser qui a
été tué par son ami mais son ami lui
avait française érotique cellule hôte
non non je pensais que je pense qu'en
tête j'ai donc la justice est un complot
la justice s'est trompée
la justice est faillible suis pas en
train de dire que la justice est
antisémite donc je lui dis qu'il ait une
attente assez calme a dit cyril alors h
attentes à la justice comme l'a dit
cyril hanouna la personne savait ce
qu'elle faisait
elle tremble et de lui l raser les murs
il a traité de sale juive en permanence
il a dit si la traitait de châtain une
fois qu'il a tué ça suffit alors